hey dudes I'm running right hey gals
I'm Randy fries so we're gonna check out
the Batman Arkham night Harley Quinn
trailer have you seen any of the batman
arkham knight trailers for the video
game i haven't seen the Harley Quinn
when this one just got released a couple
hours ago here we go I like Harley Quinn
I want a brandy to be here because she's
not working on a short film for like 16
years about being Harley Quinn she's
gonna play a Harley Quinn Harlequin
Harlequin Harlequin Harlequin Harlequin
yeah it's like what do you mean
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like the awesome she looks hot I know
Wow Wow and I love how she has the
punchlines her never lets her have the
punchlines yeah yeah I like what they're
really promoting Harley Quinn for this
new game which i think is really cool
because Harley Quinn is like a huge fan
favorite it's interesting because she
started off in the Batman animated
series yeah which is really weird
because it's not common for there to be
like a television show adaptation and
then for a character to stand out so
much they become a big part of the comic
book universe well that's how you should
think about it I'm trying to sound smart
right now over on camera
yes she's alright list the fact people
are like wow he knows what he's talking
about I forgot my glasses that it makes
me appear more intellectual no it
doesn't but yeah I mean obviously the
play is Batman but the school didn't
give me the option to be Harley Quinn
Harley Quinn is an awesome character and
she's really like she's pretty [ __ ]
hot in this trailer she looks really hot
ever seen the Margot Robbie pic yes what
do you think skanky huh
no she doesn't look skank you look
stanky no it's like a horror with Quan
makeup I like the style of Harley Quinn
in this game and they're like yeah she's
decked out with the pants the skirt the
baseball bat I like because it has an
homage to the old nurse's outfit that
she wore and it has the original one
where she wore the complete Jester
Costume with the hat and everything it
also has the dyed hair which is nice
yeah yeah I really hope we do get to
explore early Quinn more in this video
game and then in the new Suicide Squad
movie - I'm sure she's she hasn't pretty
yeah I mean the her backstory is really
interesting I had of a lot of the Batman
villains I find her backstory to be one
of the most human out of all then that's
true you know it's not like some crazy
scientist like she just psychologically
messed up she looks hot I mean that's
about my Dark Knight or her you know
what I mean it's black it's a black dark
it's bruised hey if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out brandy prices
channel it's a fun channel on there and
you can follow us on Facebook Instagram
and Twitter where if we get enough
followers we can get product placement
to put why talk more about that just
follow us [ __ ] let's do a shout out
yes it could choir hey guys how about a
shutout for your first Argentinian
female subscriber Argentinian the female
demographic on this is about 5% of this
channel yeah I've been checking the
channel for some time now and I love it
it's like watching videos with my
friends that's the idea it's like whoa
we're just hanging out on the couch
watching feet and we're like looking at
the camera so it's like we're
interacting with you at home YouTube
tricks is occur you look like a
pissed-off woman yeah you look like you
got anger issues no no no it's not that
she's a really sweet person this is
clearly just that time of the month for
her well she's just obviously she's
obviously on her period like that why do
you think she looks so sinister mad
what was she but she's doing the knife
justice by having that well there's a
knife here yeah she probably like yeah
she was the knife up against someone's
throat it's probably really sexy
yes okay you gave me a good idea yeah
I'm actually I had a friend he wasn't
really my friend he was if he was at
this party where I was and he started
talking about
he loves that knife hold up yeah it's
like what he says if I can have a gun to
my head or a knife on my throat when I'm
having sex and I love it oh yeah some
people are really into that how do you
like you can tell yes you guys really
into that too you don't know that I can
tell look at those eyes she's just it's
like when you're making that face
because you have a weapon in your
like this if this was a knife problem
yeah that's really hot yeah very sexual
what you just did oh it was like Jessica
um
continue to pleasure men with knives and
you know some of them like getting cut
so you know if you want to cut a guy do
it just not the penis that hurts what
you want to kick their thing in the
peanuts don't do that either punch line
Oh ending joke
you're the joke well there's always an
ending joke and then it cuts the black
all right we already did a joke
punchline well wacky YouTube